all right joining us now with reaction
to the disastrous special counsel report
for Joe Biden as Republican presidential
candidate Nikki Haley uh Governor
Ambassador great to have you back thank
you let's get your reaction first to
Robert her report in the press
conference the very angry one that
occurred right
after you know a few things that you
look at this I mean I think the first
thing is you look at the fact that um
you know we need to have we got to take
the politics out of all of our agencies
I mean whether this is Clinton whether
this is Biden whether this is Trump they
all need to be handled fairly and
clearly that's not the case we have to
get rid of the double standard and that
continues to show itself the second
thing is it is unbelievably disturbing
that they are showing that they see
Biden to not have a good memory that
they see him as diminished that they see
that it's a problem and they point blank
say that I mean this is actually
dangerous I mean I have said look people
make fun of the fact that I say we need
to have mental competency test there's a
reason 70% of Americans don't want to
see a Biden Trump rematch the party that
gets rid of their 80-year-old candidate
is going to be the party that wins but
the third thing that bothers me about
this is whether it's Biden or whether
it's Trump they both knew better you
know when you work around National
Security documents you know what's not
supposed to leave the office you don't
go bragging about these National
Security documents you don't go leave
them in a garage what whatever it is
both these men knew better and the
arrogance that they both had to think
they could walk out with these documents
and just not think that there were going
to be any repercussions I think is the
problem that we have with this so I mean
look it's a disturbing day for America
right now but I think we've got some
work to do isn't there a bigger problem
and that is that we don't have equal
application of our laws look at the
Hillary Clinton case yeah top secret
classified information uh subpoena
emails 33,000 deleted uh bleach bit
hammer devices SIM cards um you know it
seems to be a problem that they all have
because I don't think any of them end up
packing their own boxes and the fact
that one's criminalized one of the three
gets raided and the other two happen to
be Democrats that that reeks to me of
political
know I mean they both knew what they had
I mean Trump was bragging about his
Biden's got his in his garage they knew
what they had but the point is whether
it's Clinton whether it's Biden whether
it's Trump treat them the same and the
problem is we have politics in every
single agency in DC and we have got to
clear it up you can't serve the people
if you're going to play partisan
politics and we have seen this years trp
one have to clean these
systems president Alina Hobb just
mentioned this the presidential records
act that impacted him that did not
impact Joe that did not impact Hillary
Clinton let me move on let's talk about
your campaign I know I know you hate the
question but I've got to ask because
it's it's very real you go into Iowa you
came in third place you go into New
Hampshire you lost by double digits uh
in Nevada you none of the above
basically or not one of these candidates
at least in the primary and you didn't
take you're not going to take part in
the caucus tonight which I don't know
why you didn't do that um is there and
then we have the real clear politics
average and it I'll put it up on the
screen and in your home state of South
Carolina Donald Trump is leading 60 to
29.3% so my question is if if you go to
New Hampshire Iowa Nevada happens you
lose your home state even if you lost it
by just double digits not by 30 points
the question then becomes what is your
path to get the delegates to get the
nomination because at that point I mean
well don't you think you'd have to win
your home
state I appreciate you asking that you
you know I'll tell you it's interesting
cuz in Iowa they were all saying you
know she's never going to make it
through Iowa we started at 2% we ended
with 20% um that was no small feat when
we got rid of a dozen of the candidates
then you go into New Hampshire we got
43% of the vote but what's more
important Sean is you have to
acknowledge the Republican incumbent did
not get 43% of the vote that's alarm
Bells then you go into Nevada I mean
look we were told months ago that this
was a sham the GOP chair under
indictment he worked with Trump they
created these caucuses it's written
about in news reports you can write look
it look it up on the internet they
planned this thing in the caucus they
said that we had to pay 55,000 if we
wanted to be in the caucus with Trump
and so you know Nevada didn't mean
anything South Carolina we're going to
work it hard we're going to bring it in
but I'm telling you we better pay
attention look at what we lost you've
got Trump paying $50 million in legal
fees from his campaign donations you got
an RNC that's broke how do you beat
Biden with that you can't we have got to
have a new generational leader if we're
going to move forward this is not
personal about Trump but don't you at
some point Ambassador Governor don't you
at some point have to win something I
mean you can talk about Iowa you can
talk about New Hampshire you can check
off you know Nevada South Carolina is a
little hard to shake off when you were
the governor there for two
terms and you'll see us move we moved 25
points in New Hampshire in the those
last three weeks we're going to move in
South Carolina we don't do coronation
Sean you've got three states Notting
anybody I'm at Super Tuesday are you
denying these poll you deny the polls
anywhere you're saying they're not you
guys said that I was going to you're
saying that I was going to lose New
Hampshire by 30 points and I got 43 so
I'm saying that look South Carolina
hasn't happened yet we're doing this
because we have a country to save and
everybody's blinded by the fact that
we've got these two 80y old C I mean
Trump got me confused with Pelosi not
too long ago we need to move forward for
the Nikki Haley thank you for being with
us hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else